what makes your favorite league of
Legends champion your favorite is it
their kit their viability in the meta or
did you fall in love with their
personality and their character well
voice lines play a huge part in how that
character comes across to us on the rift
that's why I love playing Annie so much
smell like that's why this week we're
counting down the top 10 League of
Legends champions based on their voice
lines now we're gonna be fair with this
one guys one legendary one-liner is not
gonna land you at the top of our list
we're taking into account a champions
entire repertoire of lines now let's
hear the champions themselves have to
say kicking off our list at number 10 is
the glorious executioner himself welcome
to the League of Draven this egotistic
narcissist has some of the most iconic
voice lines in the game perfection I got
that Draven is giving a master class and
how to play Draven haha which naturally
are all about himself
it looks like Draven's taking a Draven
break not draven draven
and why wouldn't they be let's check out
our Opie players of the game draven
draven draven draven and Draven he may
have teammates but who cares about them
especially with this axe juggling death
machine tearing up the lane
Draven throwing the other team a bone
who wants some Draven let's check out
our featured matchup of the day
Draven versus some loser shocks better
interview me after this his flair for
the dramatic makes his voice line some
of the most fun in League of Legends
Draven was an excellent pick this game
and every game earning this grim noxian
performer a spot on our
did you know Draven can catch another
Draven's axes haha you should read the
hits more often
quirky doesn't even begin to describe
the ninth entry on our list a solid
giggle should do the trick
let's see if all the colors Loulou takes
the whimsy of the yordles to a whole new
level
never look at to it in the eye her
cutesy fanciful voice lines certainly
break the tension even in the most
dramatic of team fights
I recommend skipping no matter how
dangerous the situation with a wave of
her wand and some dubious magic words
things become well oddly with pix by her
side there's nothing the face sorceress
can't twirl through taking our number
eight spot is glad who if we're being
honest is the embodiment of your
soloqueue teammates laugh I encourage
unpredictable it's total insanity you
can rely on I don't need a team to start
a teamfight holy Sh borrowing this yodel
and his semi trusty mounts Karl know
exactly when to fight that is all the
time decorated fearless and a little
insane pled charges into every battle
with only one goal in mind to rack up
the kills I might have to jump off this
lizard and put my boot in your walk to Z
cheer I'll kill all of them myself
Shh it's time to get violent
weird but at the end of the day it seems
that all-clad wants to do is reclaim his
land or more accurately conquer the
world this land was made for me and me
alone I'm from all over
it's next to know where shuttle up
whether it's his constant yelling just
blow away so the Badgers command or his
love of tacos
after we finished murder in these folks
what do you think tacos
[Music]
no one would argue with this
cantankerous cavalier taking a spot on
our list I don't have trouble
communicating words is just treacherous
bastards our number seven champion may
say his own name more than even Draven
mundo say his own name a lot or else he
forget has happened before noodle this
purple madman has a flair for the
completely insane the mono syllabic
monstrosity indiscriminately smashes
anything in his way no matter what Lane
you're in whoa smash mudo will go where
he pleases and still somehow manages to
find the time to run an international
corporation mundo runs international
corporation as he pleases this deranged
demonized denizen of zon has
immortalized his voice in the world of
League of Legends mono goes this way ah
why talk when you can just punch people
well I guess if you're Vai you can do
both Punk's first ask questions while
punching coming in at number 6 we have
piltover z-- finest an ex gang leader
turned law enforcer alongside partner
Caitlyn vine nails the bad cop persona
care for a spot of tea or maybe a spot
of punch in the face we can either do
this the hard way or oh wait no there's
just the hard way
impulsive short-tempered and equipped
with a pair of hextech gauntlets this is
a woman you do not want to mess with
why can't I get a straight answer it's
always just oh now stop hitting me
ow my face I let my hands do the talking
she's busting her way out of the jungle
dashing through your front line and
sending you straight into the air yeah
teamwork by stands for violence
this hextech powered peacekeeping
punching machine has smashed her way
onto our list here I come to save the
day or wreck it one girl wrecking crew
the wispy whimsical and slightly
boy-crazy cosmic Herald of tar gone Zoe
comes in at number five on our list
[Music]
millenia playing with realities beyond
human comprehension the aspect of
Twilight isn't above having fun with her
space doggy or a good old-fashioned love
triangle but you'll definitely think
twice about taking her lightly if she
catches you in a sleepy trouble bubble
[Music]
Zoe's playful interactions with the rest
of the cast have helped her skip into
the top five on our list the your dolls
that have made our list thus far may
have been a little crazy but this one
takes the cake
captain Teemo on duty for our number-4
spot we're featuring people of Swift
scout Teemo size doesn't mean everything
never underestimate the power of the
scouts code though small in stature with
a cheerful personality Teemo reminds us
that looks can be deceiving turns out I
got a proficiency in killing
killings on good at and with his time on
the Omega squad it becomes quite obvious
that this little guy is a stone-cold
natural-born killer war didn't change me
I changed war never get attached but the
poison do its work site sure three look
from his blinding blow darts two noxious
mushroom traps Teemo uses poison in
various disturbing ways keeping you on
your toes once worn to the Bandol Scouts
code
Teemo does not mess around when it comes
to his convictions some mask you'll
never take off but war war changes
everyone nobody's innocent anymore
one of the first champions designed by
riot annie is a league of Legends staple
and comes in at number three on this
list while still a child annie is not
afraid to dish it out with the most
powerful mages
meeny miny burn don't be a scaredy cat
alongside her teddy bear Tibbers have
you seen my bear Tibbers who is equal
parts cuddly and terrifying and he
incinerates the competition with a quick
flash ultimate all with a skip in her
step our runner-up is the maestro of
mayhem and madness rules are made to be
broken
people jinx is known for causing chaos
with her multitude of chem tech
explosives and advanced weaponry I'm
trying to shoot you shot other guys this
blue haired alien will blow you up with
her super mega death rocket laughing
hysterically while she does it
[Music]
jinks clearly loves what she does you
know what I call five dead enemies a
great start
who's next and her joy well twisted is
admirable guns don't kill people I mean
then they kill everything I'm wearing
lots of belts
okay she's a lunatic I'm crazy but at
least she keeps things interesting for
piltover finest by Stan's
welcome to snoresville hat lady
population you all right we can have
okay guys we lied in the intro it turns
out that having a single cheeky
one-liner will take you to the top of
this list oh good because for our
first-place finish we have none other
than the armor Dillo Grannis good no one
really knows what ramus is there are
those who speculate that he's the last
of a dying species run the superstitious
swear he's a harbinger of change bid
some even believe that he's an ascended
being an ancient God who rolls to
Serena's aid in its times of need all
right we asked him about his thoughts on
the rumors
all right well one thing's for sure
Ramis will be rolling his way into your
lane and it's very little you can do
about it well guys that's our list for
this week now if you didn't agree with
it I got one line for you shut your
mouth Oh them badgers are listening
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]